[Music]
doing your work and putting it in front
of an audience starting the work
finishing it and presenting it is the
most important education you can get
i'm wondering if being an office temp
for the 12 years that you did it and
then doing the writing on the side or in
free time
fueled you because if you'd had a more
comfortable job where maybe money wasn't
an option and trying to book work
maybe you would have given up on the
screenwriting
i don't think i
just personally the way i'm built i
would have i i frequently gave up on
jobs
rather than than have them interfere
with my what i thought was my career um
but i do think that it is
i think that life can
really challenge people trying to be
artists that the demands of real life
it's hard it is hard to build a way to
get some time and to feel it's worth it
when it's an abnormal thing to do it's
not it most people aren't doing it and
most people's lives don't require it
most people have
perfectly fine lives without writing a
novel or a screenplay or doing you know
whatever it is that that an artist wants
to do
and and i think it's important to
recognize that you are
doing something
a little offbeat
and that the most important thing i
think you can do is find a way to
comfortably do it
in
the spaces you have to do it in whatever
they are
there are some people who would rather
work for six months and then take two
months off and have the two months to
really work um and other people would
rather work an hour a day
or every other weekend or whatever it is
you have to you have to look at yourself
you have to see what's productive for
you there's no right or wrong um the the
novelist simone as french mystery
novelist um thriller novelist he used to
write in intensely short bursts he would
he would plan out a novel and then
reportedly he had a separate house built
in his backyard because he could and he
would go to this other house
and he would not talk to his family they
would drop the meals at the front door
and for like two weeks and he wrote
short novels
he would be like don't bother me i'm
writing and he would go in
and then he would
come out with a novel a couple weeks
later and then he would live his life
and then next time around he would go
back in
that's fine there's other people who you
know just
like me office temping a half hour here
half an hour there at other people's
desks or
like i happen to be a morning person so
i would get up extra early and work in
the morning before work but don't
discount
the amount of
pressure
that real life puts on your art and i
would say the thing to do is
adapt your art to fit that life you know
if you
um
like throwing all these references
around uh the painter matisse
when he got older he couldn't stand at
his easel and paint anymore and he ended
up um
doing these cut outs he would take paper
and cut out figures and they became
gorgeous artwork called the cutouts
there's a book called jazz and a lot of
other work he stopped painting he
couldn't physically paint anymore he
shifted his creativity to something he
physically could do
that i think is a really good lesson for
everyone it's like
if you
can't
find
the time to do it the way you think you
should like i thought i had to have an
eight-hour free day with a lot of iced
tea and music playing and i found that
it was better to write little tiny
slices even just a sentence or a
paragraph if you keep doing a sentence
or a paragraph you will eventually get
whatever it is you need
if you wait till you have the whole day
free you may never
um so that that sort of is what i think
you have to do in the face of that
inevitable conflict
and that conflict even happens when
you're a professional writer i would run
into the problem of you know i'm working
on a project
a show or a movie or something i had a
project i was dying to do and sometimes
i would have to like
take a break from my writing job so my
job was writing but i had to stop to
do a little indie film that i wanted to
do and so i didn't take work for
as long as i could afford and then i
would go back to work
everybody has this problem the important
thing
is to really
pay attention to what is productive for
you
if that's writing a little bit at a time
if that's writing for short bursts a lot
whatever works
i just wasn't sure if
however painful or maybe not so painful
some of these temp jobs were i know some
tempting can be great and some can be
probably excruciating
did that fuel you the painful moments to
keep going and also too you're around
people that this is their life
they're like lifers at this company and
did you say i don't want to be that guy
yeah
yeah well
it's sort of i mean
to a certain extent this may it sounds
horrible i generally look around and say
i don't want to be that guy
just going to the store yeah
but what it did do was inform me about
all the parts of life that i didn't know
to find out what it's like to work in
this type of place and that type of i
worked in a lot of different places and
in fact the first novel i wrote was
about
a wannabe screenwriter who was an office
temp so i guarantee you nothing nothing
gets lost on a an artist who's making
his way in the world you got to be
absorbing all of it and writing it down
how did you take control of your
creative fate i think recognizing that
the only thing an artist truly controls
is the work itself and that is not an
original thought to me many
far better artists have said it
you can't control
whether your work sells whether it is
popular even
people who have sold and had hits will
find themselves doing something and it
flops that's
just
predictable that that will happen so if
if they can't control it if they can't
guarantee a hit if they can't guarantee
that people like it
how should we
there's no way for anyone to know
how things are going to work out
creatively and the way that you become a
happy artist and a productive artist is
to give up worrying about it you say i
am
gambling i am rolling the dice on this
thing because i like it because i think
it's fun because i think other people
will like it
i think that's a big part of it just
saying i am completing this because i
want it complete it has nothing to do
with whether or not someone else will
like it
you should at the same time adjust your
expectations if you are writing about a
very obscure topic or in an obscure
genre
then don't expect
a big budget
plan one of the things i had to learn
was
if i want to write something weird and
offbeat write it so that i can do it
myself with a video camera and a couple
actors that i get together learn how to
do things diy learn how to you know
work within the limits that you
can control and then you're controlling
your creative fight
and then if somebody likes it great if
somebody doesn't like it at least you
did it and you're more likely to do the
next thing better from having completed
work and put it out there and seeing the
response there is nothing like it for an
artist to see people respond to your
work and it's one of the things that
screenwriters get to do very
infrequently
most working screenwriters most of their
jobs they don't get out to the public a
lot of people do drafts of things that
don't get made
now you you
do that less because most people are
working on shows when you work on a show
they don't hire you if they're not going
to make it but
the experience of
doing your work and putting it in front
of an audience starting the work
finishing it and presenting it is the
most important education you can get
there's nothing else that that replaces
it so the more you can do that without
asking someone's permission without
waiting until someone says well this
will make me a lot of money so i will
invest in it because people don't people
don't put money into artworks because
they like them mostly they put money
into artworks because they think it'll
make them more money so if you do
something
that's
good but not profitable
you won't get to make it it's better to
do something that's good and can be made
really really cheaply and then you can
make it nobody can stop you and if you
don't feel like directing it yourself
somebody who does know how to work low
budget will be able to make it
so completing projects is very important
to you is that completing the process
the artistic process is the
best education you can get um if you
can
write 10 scripts and finish them and
ideally at least get a reading of them
but but really the best thing to do is
to shoot them find a way to get someone
to shoot your script
make it shorts
whatever
that will teach you more than any other
education about screenwriting and if
they're bad so what you know do it in
such a way that if you lose your money
it's not the end of the world
you